[Music]
everyone knows you can't trust sweets
that's overtly sweetest Japan has a
perfect record we're number two we try
harder guys if we failed wait a minute
weren't they just on the second floor
how'd they get down to the first floor
in the middle of that sentence they even
listening movie hilariously declares
itself as a clever send up of the horror
genre and it's so fucking great I have
to remove us in look I don't care how
wink wink it's this movie is there's no
way Dana would be prancing around in her
panties with in full view of the
neighborhood and with the window open
professor quad wow this movie went balls
deep in the cold-cocking got Bechdel
test into smithereens right off the bat
didn't it and if Holden's cute as Kurt
says he is wow this movie broke the
Bechdel test twice in 30 seconds that's
a failed Bechdel test inside a failed
Bechdel test which is like still like
two Bechdel test was this dude waiting
for the football to come through the
window
considering that Thor told the women to
think fast my guess is no he wasn't also
didn't this guy driving see this dude
out in the street before he slammed on
the brakes there was an issue before the
ball was thrown right and you have no
pants
yeah but she's been dancing in front of
open windows all day so I highly doubt
she's all that concerned still even if
he was it's highly doubtful that she
would have forgotten this he blown this
town driving a very counterintuitive
manner the comically large coffee travel
mug bong is brought to you by Cheech
Marin Starbucks collection cops will
never pull over a man with a huge bong
in his car well sure right when he's
white why did these people hang out with
Marty this is a mix of people that
walked out of the J Crew catalog but
they pal around with one super hippie
guy that's high all the time he's good
for a few laughs sure but this is a
four-person trip with five people if you
know what I mean
nest is empty or right on time how long
is this asshole been on the roof what if
they'd left from Kurt's house and why
didn't they leave from Kurt's house
considering it's his van what shit
Daniel Truman said this outfit that's
highly reliant on security decides to
make an important new hire on their
biggest day of the year this close sign
makes me think maybe this place is
closed
my cousin bought a house up there you go
through like an Mountain tunnellers in
Lake
so is Kurt's cousin complicit in this
crazy conspiratorial crusade and later
Dana says she thinks Kurt doesn't even
have a cousin so what the fuck was a
story behind this can
that they later prance around in
swimsuits it's obviously a beautiful and
temperate day but Marty needs four
layers to keep him nice and snuggled
southern CVI eagle of Sutton instead
only for us the audience a real eagle
would have sniffed out the danger and
flown far away from this bullsh but
whatever also this is one of the few
missteps this movie makes showing us
this electronic and visible security
grid right now is dumb we've got plenty
of evidence something is funky from the
cuts to Bradley Whitford and Richard
Jenkins and this undercuts the potential
shock of the later scene when the elder
Hemsworth motorcycles himself into the
grid and dies a hilarious and shocking
death why did they need a camper to
drive out to the cabin it's clearly less
than a day's Drive and the cabin is
where they're all sleeping they could
have all fit into Marty's Volvo and
saved on gas let's park super far away
from the cabin so we have to drag all
our gear in just a really long way
brilliant how we're slowing down
cognition the hair dye dumb blonde very
artistic works its way into the blood
the scalp or you could spend much less
time and money recruiting Dumber kids
there are literally millions of horny
athletic bookish drunk and virginal
teenagers out there but they had to pick
the ones that are academic all-stars
the Lambs have passed through the gate
they are come to the killing floor so
wait this is a professional setting
where people in lab coats construct
horror scenarios but this guy is an
actual horror movie nutjob how do you
find these guys to work for you
Craigslist this is super impressive
information but now that they keeping
track of the pulse and blood pressure
there aren't any electrodes on their
bodies no they've already been picked
what
No who took him maintenance maintenance
they picked the same thing every year
then why would you have tried to submit
their pic as your own also rounds an
intern so it's odd that he would know
what maintenance picks every year how
long has he been an intern are the
career paths that tough to advance in
the shady secretive religious NSA style
operation no it's gambling casually on
actual human deaths letting off steam
would be playing ping-pong in the break
room or jamming to Bon Jovi in the
locker room yeah we rigged the game as
much as we need to but in the end they
don't transgress they can't be punished
this is still a weird system if they
need the victims to make the wrong
choice or it doesn't count then how
about all the other manipulations that
led them to that wrong choice they
basically changed the people through
chemicals in so how does that not factor
into it
please enjoy the music while the camera
follows this girl's ass through the
cabin I dare you to make out with that
wall this is the first dare out of the
gate it just started this game and the
stone motherfucker dials up the dares do
11 right off the bat forcible wolf
tonguing also they all clap for her
instead of vomiting the wind must have
blown over because that's the thing that
happens that makes what kind of sense I
spoke too soon but also stoner guy would
be excellent at cinema since what do you
think's down there
I don't know but by god it better not be
another being infinity stone yeah
Tennyson to some weird like collecting
memorabilia from old Tom Hanks movies
okay he opens a music box this chick
takes a necklace off a mannequin this
idiot touches some film and this Thor
motherfuckers tinkering with the sphere
but this movie will choose this girl's
diary opening as the act that decides
which evil creature will assault these
people Jules doesn't put the necklace on
just because Dana said something and
even if this would have stopped her for
a moment she definitely would have put
it on anyway while she waited for Dana
to speak April for father was cross with
me and said I lacked the true faith
Ruby reads part of the script to the
witch several years before it was
written I have found it in the oldest
books the way of saving our family too
bad these people aren't good enough at
cinemasins or else they would have asked
themselves why Ana patience Buckner
didn't just say this Latin phrase
herself while she was still alive to
write it in a diary
30 straight pink seconds of zombie
rising footage that's too dark to tell
what the hell these things actually look
like hang on you're telling me that out
of all the departments no one took
demons that's bullshit man I'm calling
bullshit on this death sports book also
damn it I have to take one set off for
the movie referencing the Deadites in
the Evil Dead trilogy stop entertaining
me so much movie yes you did yes you had
zombies but this is zombie redneck
torture family see they're entirely
separate species yeah but how do you
distinguish between witches and sexy
witches
isn't that a subjective thing okay I got
a boner for the ugly witch too looking
at this board how the hell were they
supposed to choose half the things
written here while they were in the
cellar
everything in our staple is remnant of
the old world my god we have this newbie
on the team so we can get some proper
expositing you get used to it
should you overly ethical guys in the
wrong job I am never gonna see him on
that ever can't he just go down to the
place where they keep the Merman and
request to see it
we need the Japanese crew to get it done
the shot of the ghosts in Japan is
goddamn hilarious but I'm tempted to
remove a sin but the fact that the
director needs an athlete
and a fool in addition to a scholar and
a virgin for proper sacrifice makes this
grade school setting definitely sinful
they came up from the basement and this
girl was still so sexed up she did a
twerk dance in front of the fire and
everyone forgot the basement full of
freaky some of which they touched though
to be fair we're eyewitness to this
particular fireplace dance I also would
have forgotten basically my entire life
up until that moment he's on full
academic scholarship and now he's
calling his friend an egghead
we got the explanation about the dumbing
Jules down from the hair dye but what
skirts excuse for suddenly turning into
a Neanderthal Payne lives the flesh only
they brought that thing back upstairs
with him why wait a minute when Dana
read that Latin thing a minute ago she
said it was nothing like she knew what
it meant before she read it assuming it
was gibberish now we find out she
doesn't know Latin at all so why the did
she think it was nothing okay baby show
us the goods does it really matter if we
see we're not the only ones watching
Kent
gotta keep the customer satisfied this
scene makes no sense as long as the gods
know that she's a whore that should
suffice
but they make the fact that we need to
see Jules Jules a requirement for the
sacrifice does satisfy and the customer
also mean that the zombie redneck
torturer family stabs hands before they
stab something more vital also I suppose
that satisfying the customer also means
having a lot of quick cuts during a dark
scene so you don't know what the fuck is
going on how did they get the blood from
the cabin grounds to the temple so
quickly pop quiz are these two kissing
because they actually hit it off her
because everyone else in this cabin has
disappeared after a bunch of sexy
dancing thought there'd be stars this is
a tip-off to him that he's not in
reality and that'll be important later
but the sin is for the fact that these
detail obsessed horror movie making
business underlings down under never
thought to put stars in the sky like not
even once how the hell did Kurt run all
the way up to Marnie without making one
bit of noise he just said she was dead
so you're basically saying you don't
believe it thought he's a jock dickhead
but still he was her boyfriend who
enjoyed finger well-reasoned does he
have right now do I
this zombie redneck torturer dude
bothered to carry Jules head all the way
to the cabin some what for the scares
but mainly because he's an asshole no
matter what happens we have to stay
together
calm down watch the master work by
pressing some buttons and releasing
chemicals into the air what a freakin
master also how does Hadley not know
about the magic chemical that makes
people want to split up rather than stay
together guys been on the job since at
least 1998 also there's a chemical that
makes you want to split up but not stay
together also why is Kurt the only one
of them that's affected by this terribly
specific decision-making gasps this
outfit surveillance gear so tight a high
as stoner just discovered it after
knocking over a goddamn lamp chem
department I need 500 cc's of Thorazine
pump into room 3 no no no no dude a
Buckner to the rescue yeah but why not
just go ahead and pump the Thorazine
anyway I'm sure there have been people
that have survived five intraoral
attacks directly to their spine but I'm
guessing they typically don't
immediately go on a walk fight and
eventually be the hero my point is Marty
is fucking dead and despite no proof of
the stoners death these underground
business assholes go ahead and pull the
second death lever prematurely I mean
they were monitoring their health right
also we eventually discovered this is
zombie Judas blood since he's been
killed by Marty somehow but do zombies
even have blood and if they do is it
this red human color thank God for that
two-way mirror earlier so that he could
see this and saver am i right he came
back to life after the crowbar stabbing
so let's stab him with a knife over and
over god this girl is stupid also this
is the problem with monsters even in
meta horror movies the zombie can't be
killed even if it's been dismembered but
for whatever reason it stops on being
after Dana knifes him in the chest a few
times this guy got a metal claw to the
back that pulled him up to the ceiling
he should not be able to stand up and do
regular right now how'd the ever-loving
does Curt know this did he climb down
into a cave pool and have a vision while
we weren't watching okay gonna take off
three Sims here for this scene it's
pretty damn hilarious also even though I
love the scene I'm gonna ask why does
Japan need to kill 20 innocent
schoolgirls while America has to kill
five stupid college kids what's the
minimum amount of death required doesn't
need to be a hundred percent there could
they get away with killing only three or
four people and calling it a day also I
go back to the satisfied customer thing
if they demand nudity and sex then Japan
already failed with this nine-year-old
schoolgirl scenario in the bag how hard
is it to kill nine-year-old it's obvious
Japan and the u.s. have both succeeded
in sacrifice in previous years and maybe
even more countries have so what happens
that shouldn't they get a bonus year if
they deposit more than one sacrifice per
year whatever you
Racing 2 in order to close the tunnel he
has to go through locker rooms and that
just feels like a total and complete
failure of planning we didn't get the or
didn't get the order you mean there's a
scenario by which you wouldn't have
caused that cave-in wouldn't this just
be standard protocol to cave in the
tunnel under every circumstance out of
does he know how to do that he just ran
from his usual post and king hot-wired
someone else's to explode instantly out
of also they blew the tunnel manually
which could have ended up killing these
guys on its own which if I'm watching
this movie correctly means they would
have this whole thing up by killing them
like this and hold back he's about to
jump a gorge and try to rescue everyone
and you tell him this because you are a
screenwriter cliche of a character don't
hold back man give it your all don't get
up beat all you get this bad ass reveal
completely neutered by the previous
scene of the eagle flying into the grid
and falling thanks for tipping your
hands super early movie also this force
field is totally against what this
institution is about and it's kind of
strange that even bothered to install
this thing because if there are any
witnesses to watching someone try it go
across it doesn't the whole scenario is
suddenly called into question another
thing how are they getting the blood
from these people and how does the blood
travel from anywhere in their little
horror park to the right place does a
little needle poked out of the ground in
any random spot they happen to die and
then that is connected to some other
system which delivers the blood to the
inner sanctum ok no matter what happens
got a stick are you telling me this
asshole was just waiting back here
biding his time looking for a dramatic
opportunity to kill this dude she's
still alive
the Virgin's death is optional as long
as it's last and convenient to the plot
also they assume she's the virgin but
has anyone made an attempt to keep Dana
safe from being killed before anyone
else she could have been axed by the
intruder to a room long ago this redneck
zombie dick hasn't killed Dana yet
apparently he needed to work on his
biceps before killing her working out is
so inconvenient absolutely totally dead
and super tardy stoner ex machina a
super tardy Marty party also not only
can a copy Vaughn hold up to a heavy
metal chain and claw weed can cure a
severed spine
who knew also Marty killed zombie Judah
out of the camera view but he still had
to walk all this way back to the dock so
why didn't the cameras pick him up then
zombie that we'll never see again is
still alive just FYI
marty is suddenly a capable electrician
because everyone in this movie has the
gift of convenient characteristics he
successfully got this elevator to go
down but that's it how did he ensure
they'd stop in places where they could
see monsters but not be killed but this
is basically a haunted elevator ride but
how are they moving this thing after
started in the grave and when the hell
do we get to David s pumpkins and what
exactly keeps this ghost behind the
glass again is how we die except you too
of course who have managed to sneak into
the actual facility controlling all this
you're going to die by completely
different means I'm guessing now that
you've infiltrated the compound and
broken the entire sacrificial death
model nice shot but this method of
monster storage seems way too complex
and impossible for any kind of
efficiency they put out an alert to the
entire building to take these two kids
out but this poor incompetent bastard
was the only one to show up at the
actual elevator that they are now
controlling Marty who is definitely dead
slams this guards head against the
elevator and the car dies immediately
meanwhile Marty's insides were totally
ripped out and he gets to walk around
and be alive and stuff Dana and Marty
have some excellent regenerative
abilities not only did Marty take a
travel to the pink back earlier tonight
just 9 minutes ago Dana was spewing up
blood whoever's voice this is seriously
thinks this situation is a talking-to
away from being contained even though
we've been told that Dana has to outlast
Marty in order for the Ancient Ones to
be sated these guys just start blasting
away with no caution whatsoever
Dana somehow knows how to work this
control board in order to unleash all
the monsters also why would you ever
have a control board set up where you
could unleash all the monsters this is
one of the best scenes of the decade
also this is a great shot but there's no
way that snake could have fit in that
elevator car requesting immediate
reinforcements code black
Truman saw Black Widow fruitlessly cock
her gun against nan gonna blow opponents
in The Avengers and was compelled to get
in on that sweet useless gun cocking
action Marty and Dana get out of the
control room but this is monster central
because the elevators keep taking
monsters here yet there's only a few
obstacles for them when they run out
making their escape too easy are you
afraid of unicorns it will be just how
the patients get down here does she also
know how to manually override the
elevator controls the one redeemable
character working at this place
unceremoniously dies despite the fact
that he was the only one who seemed to
have a conscience and yeah sure he blows
up these zombies real good but what a
lame ending for this character what was
the thought process of this monster from
wherever he is I'll just randomly
destroy the floor and hopefully I'll get
something to eat in the process Chi the
worst pronoun game is when someone is
dying and uses it a virgin
we work with what we have if we're
supposedly saving a bunch of demons
known as the ancient ones they certainly
would know whether or not someone's a
virgin right why are they so easily
fooled by appearances also you had two
girls one was a dedicated student in a
committed relationship and the other
just had an improper sexual tryst with
her teacher but you chose jewels to make
into a whore and Dena is the Virgin the
ancient ones the gods that used to rule
the earth as long as they accept our
sacrifice they remain below
yeah but make them go down there in the
first place also hasn't this one also
failed though considering the stoner
survived and both he and the Virgin made
their way through the compound into the
stone ritual room
this werewolf bites Dana right in the
jugular but she will survive this is the
director a supernatural being or just a
fatass older lady that can fairly easily
kick a younger man's ass redneck zombie
ax machina patient seems to know that
the director needs to be killed since
she bypassed Dana on the stairs because
she saw how much time was left in the
movie and wanted to move this belong as
a cousin this may be the most
unbelievable part of this movie everyone
has a cousin of some sort also how the
hell would Dana know the length of his
familial Reach
fortunately I am mighty
Barty I love you you're really high Oh
[Music]
whole world Marty is in your hands Dana
Dana only Zuul this stuff looks really
old this forest is old very old
this is the end it's actually kind of a
rush they say you are visions that your
life flashes before your eyes that all
your dreams come true
Marty I know you are in the building I
know you can hear me you should not have
come back Marty and if our friendship
had meant anything to you at all that's
the way you should have left it but you
always had to be the one to win don't
you